c'est les primaires de la gauche
aujourd'hui pas de regret aucun jamais
de regrette arnaud montebourg c'est
lance dans la course à la primaire en
jouant sur les symboles le cadre une
péniche sur la seine baptisé
rosa-bonheur parti françois hollande
décidé d'outrepasser la primaire de se
présenter au suffrage universel des
français contre la primaire ce serait la
fin la destruction finale du parti
socialiste par console on lui fait durer
le suspense sur ses intentions le chef
de l'état qui ce matin a remis des
médailles aux champions des jeux
olympiques et des jeux paralympiques de
rio
pourquoi la gauche en l1 parce que la
gauche et probablement aujourd'hui la
plus bête du monde
aujourd'hui je suis conscient des
risques que ferait courir une démarche
la mienne qui ne rassemblerait pas
l'agent largement autour d'elle est-ce
que la loyauté de monsieur valls soit
pas lui coûter finalement sa candidature
je peux pas spoiler dernier épisode
aussi j'ai décidé de ne pas être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle au
renouvellement donc de mon mandat
il a lui-même fait état de son bilan de
la situation de la france et de tout ce
qu'il y a fait avec eux aussi l'état des
échecs relatifs et de ses regrets pré
départ de alain juppé nicolas sarkozy
françois hollande c'est très bien il
faut que ça continue tous les anciens
premiers ministres tous ceux qui veulent
revenir dans la course les anciens
ministres n'ayant rien à faire et je
crois que françois hollande
après nicolas sarkozy alain juppé peut
donner ce signal du grand coup de balai
nécessaire et compte tenu du contexte je
crois que c'est une décision courageuse
à prendre il l'a prise au nom à droite
françois fillon lourd lui la lucidité de
françois hollande ce soir le président
de la république a donné avec le cid é
té que son échec patent lui interdit
d'aller plus loin je ressent évidemment
d'abord l'homme qui dans son plaidoyer
était émouvant mais il a pris là une
décision qui je crois a été sage elle
été difficile mais réaliste et empreint
de lucidité je veux pas faire le
commentaire sur la personne c'est un
énorme aveu d'échec et je crois qu'il
faudrait pas que ça fonctionne comme une
amnistie pour tous ceux qui ont
participé à cet échec marketing décision
évidemment éminemment respectable elle
ouvre la voie au premier ministre qui
avait
ici beaucoup jouer des coudes pour en
arriver là et c'est ce qui va se passer
puisque la suite logique c'est la
démission de manuel valls et la
candidature de manuel valls qui devrait
intervenir je pense aux moustiques
envers les français qui on voulait plus
voir les fronts seuils de 10 et à
travers ce sondage il le disait
différentes manières il le disait sur
les marchés il le disait entre il en
voulait plus et donc bon cette question
c'est une forme de lucidité par cas les
mois qui viennent on de voir mon seul
devoir sera de continuer à diriger le
pays celui que vous m'avez confiées en
2012 en me consacrant pleinement et dans
le document le plus total à la
république vive la république et vive la
france
[Musique]